why am I the weirdo why am I the weirdo
for choosing to do lunges or stretches
in the middle of a crowded shop you know
I've always spoken to the importance of
being active and moving throughout the
day and how this can improve our General
Health and well-being it's especially
important to break up long periods of
sitting with a little movement so you
don't seize up so here I am in the
middle of a crowded coffee shop doing
deep lunges or maybe standing in a queue
doing calf raises and you feel like an
absolute weirdo everyone's staring at
you but why is that why is movement so
denormalized that you feel strange for
doing it this is objectively good for
you it's something everyone should be
doing and yet we feel scared to get out
of our seats because it's so weird when
you're walking along a pavement and you
choose to balance along the wall like a
child instead that's objectively more
fun there's no reason not to do it but
nobody does likewise why is it weird to
crawl around the field instead of
jogging around a field it's legitimately
just as useful a form of exercise okay
yeah maybe the crawling through the
streets think is pretty weird you guys
weird too let me know and bye for now